From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Nancy Updike filling in for Ira Glass. Today's show is a rerun, a good one, and I'm going to start with this story that I want to share. It's a little personal.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Nancy Updike，代班Ira Glass。今天的节目是重播，而且是很棒的一期，我要从这个我想分享的故事开始。这事儿有点私人。
I was at MAC, the makeup store, not the computer store. And I was buying foundation, which I almost never wear. It's the makeup you put all over your face to give yourself the pretend perfect skin. And I asked the salesman for help finding the right color.
当时我在MAC，是那家化妆品店，不是电脑店。我在买粉底液，但我几乎从不用这东西。就是那种涂满全脸，让你看起来拥有完美肌肤的伪装。我让店员帮我挑个合适的色号。
And he looked at me, and he said-- almost like he was thinking out loud-- he said, your neck, it's so much more yellow than your face. And then he turned away to start looking for the impossible color that would solve this problem of the yellow right next to the so-much-more-yellow.
他看着我，几乎像是自言自语地说——他说，你的脖子，比你的脸黄多了。然后他转过身，开始寻找那种不可能存在的颜色，好去解决这块“黄”和旁边那块“更黄”之间的色差问题。
And if you're thinking, oh, this was just a sales technique to invent a problem and then offer to fix it with more products, I wish that had been the case. But this was not an upsell. This was a cri de coeur. The man really just seemed to be expressing his frustration at this stumper of my mismatched face and neck.
如果你觉得，噢，这不过是推销手法，先制造一个问题再用更多产品来解决，我真希望是这样。但这根本不是为了推销，这是一种发自内心的感慨。那个男人看起来真的只是在为我那张脸和脖子不搭的问题而感到抓狂。
This sort of out-of-the-blue, perfectly sharpened comment stops you cold, because it's not an insult. It's an observation that is true. You just hadn't thought of it before. It's shocking, because you think, I know myself. I know what I've got, what I haven't got. No one's going to spot something about me that I haven't already seen. Not true. You can be among friends, doing something you love, feeling great.
这种突如其来的、精准到位的评价会让你当场石化，因为它不是侮辱。这是一个事实，只是你之前没意识到。这很震惊，因为你会想，我了解自己。我知道我有什么，没什么。没人能发现我还没看出来的问题。但事实并非如此。你可能正和朋友在一起，做着喜欢的事，感觉棒极了。
We were backstage, getting ready to go on, preparing.
我们在后台，准备上场，正在做着准备。
This is Dee Watson. She was in a play a while back.
这是Dee Watson。她以前演过一部戏。
And it was all Black women. We were all-- some of us or most of us were a little bit bigger than the average, you know. And it was a supportive atmosphere. And the subject of big behinds came up. And me having one, I know all about it. And one of the younger cast members-- she was about 25-- said, my mother thought your butt was so big, it had to be a prop.
全都是黑人女性。我们都……有些或大部分人的体型都比平均水平要丰满一些，你懂的。那是一个很有支持感的氛围。然后话题就转到了大屁股上。作为一个有这种身材的人，我对此再清楚不过了。其中一位年轻的演员——她大概25岁——说，我妈以为你的屁股那么大，肯定是垫了假体。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
And at that moment, I didn't hear anything else anybody said. I just was-- that was echoing through my head. And I could hear everybody laughing, and oh, my gosh, that's so funny. And I'm standing there, about-- I wanted to cry. I really wanted to cry. And I really don't think this young girl really meant to hurt me.
那一刻，我没听见任何人还说了什么。我只是……那句话在我的脑海里回荡。我能听到大家在笑，哦，天哪，那太好笑了。我站在那儿，大概……我想哭。我真的想哭。而且我真的觉得那个小姑娘不是故意要伤害我。
Well, and maybe it's like, we're all women, and so--
嗯，可能就像是，我们都是女性，所以……
Yeah.
是啊。
--you know, it's safe here to say anything.
……你知道，在这里说什么都是安全的。
Yeah. I think she thought I would think that was funny. And I did not.
对。我觉得她以为我会觉得那很好笑。但我并没有。
These are not statements that a human being forgets. The moment you hear the observation, it becomes part of how you see yourself, seemingly forever. Even something tiny, if it hits you right, can turn into this chirpy little voicemail that your brain is never able to erase.
这些话是人不会忘记的。当你听到那种评价的瞬间，它就变成了你自我认知的一部分，似乎永远如此。即使是很小的事情，只要正中红心，就会变成大脑永远无法删除的一条恼人的语音留言。
And it doesn't have to be about looks. It can be a comment on how you run or laugh or drive, how much money you make, or what books you've read or haven't read-- any outside assessment of you that you never saw coming and could not shake once it was uttered. One of our former producers, Jane Feltes-- she's actually now Jane Marie-- years ago, dated a man who she later decided was a jerk. He wanted to make her feel insecure. But one night, they were watching TV, and her feet were sticking up out of the blanket.
而且这不一定关于外貌。可以是关于你走路、大笑或开车的方式，你赚多少钱，或者你读过什么书没读过什么书——任何你意想不到且一旦出口就挥之不去的外部评价。我们以前的一位制作人Jane Feltes——她现在叫Jane Marie——多年前曾和一个后来被她认定是混蛋的男人约会。他想让她感到自卑。但有一天晚上，他们在看电视，她的脚从毯子里露了出来。
And he turned to me, and he said, oh, you have juice box toes. And I was like, what? And he said, yeah, like Fred Flintstone feet. He's a caveman, literally, a caveman-- a cartoon of a cave-- a chubby, squat, cartoon of a caveman.
他转过身，对我说，噢，你的脚趾像果汁盒。我当时就想，什么？他说，是啊，像弗莱德·弗林特斯通（《摩登原始人》主角）的脚。他是个穴居人，真的是个穴居人——一个胖乎乎、矮墩墩的穴居人动画形象。
And I know it sounds so stupid, because who cares what shape my toes are? But you do want the person that you're in love with to just think that every part of you is amazing and beautiful, or shut up about it. Or shut up about it.
我知道这听起来很蠢，因为谁在乎脚趾长什么样呢？但你确实希望你所爱的人觉得你全身每一个部位都是惊人且美丽的，或者闭嘴别提这事。或者干脆闭嘴。
Maybe they're ugly. I don't know. Now that I'm looking at them, I don't know. My big toe is definitely square.
也许它们确实很丑。我不知道。现在我看着它们，我不知道。我的大脚趾确实是方的。
When I get shy kids, one of the things I do with them is I try to give them permission to make fun of me.
当遇到害羞的孩子时，我做的一件事就是试图给他们“嘲笑我”的许可。
This is a fifth-grade teacher named Matthew Dicks, who is either the bravest or the most foolhardy man in America.
这是一位叫Matthew Dicks的五年级老师，他要么是全美最勇敢的人，要么是最冒失的人。
And they often come out of their shells by becoming the person who can taunt the teacher.
他们通常会通过成为那个能戏弄老师的人，从而走出自己的壳。
That sounds very dangerous.
那听起来很危险。
No. (LAUGHING) It is. I mean, you have to teach them where the line is. And sometimes I don't know where the line is either, so.
不。（笑）确实是。我是说，你得教他们界限在哪里。有时候连我自己都不知道界限在哪里，所以。
A few years ago, there was a girl in his class-- very shy. And she got the nod that it was OK for her to make fun of Matthew if she wanted.
几年前，他班里有个女孩——非常害羞。她得到了“可以嘲笑Matthew”的准许，如果她想的话。
So one day, she came in, and she just walked in very casually, and she looked at me, and she said, Hi, Jerry. And I looked at her, and I said, Jerry? And she said, never mind, and she just walked away.
所以有一天，她走进来，走得很随意，她看着我，说，嘿，Jerry。我看着她，说，Jerry？她说，没什么，然后就走开了。
And I knew she was setting me up for some joke. And it went on for days. She would-- just every time she'd walk by me, she'd say, hey, Jerry. How's it going?
我知道她是在给我下套。这持续了好几天。她会……每次路过我身边，都会说，嘿，Jerry。怎么样了？
And so finally, after about a week, I couldn't take it anymore. And she came in one morning, and she said, how you doing, Jerry? And I said, fine. Who is Jerry? And she said, Jerry is your bald spot.
所以最后，大概一周后，我实在受不了了。一天早上她进来，说，你怎么样，Jerry？我说，挺好。Jerry是谁？她说，Jerry就是你的秃斑。
Yikes.
天哪。
And I tried to play it off like, I don't have a bald spot. Go sit down. Give me a break. Ha, ha. That was, like, the most ridiculous week-long joke I've ever heard in my life. But as soon as my kids left the room to go to gym, I ran to the bathroom, and I leaned over the sink. And at the very top of my head, I had a bald spot that I had no idea about.
我试图掩饰说，我没有秃斑。快坐下。饶了我吧。哈哈。那是我这辈子听过最荒谬的整周玩笑。但孩子们一去上体育课，我就跑进卫生间，弯腰对着洗手池。在头顶最上方，我真的有一块秃斑，我对此一无所知。
Hey, can I ask a logistical question? How does a fifth-grader spot the top of your head?
嘿，能问个逻辑问题吗？一个五年级的孩子是怎么看到你头顶的？
Oh, so in my classroom, I teach Shakespeare to my students. And we have a stage in my classroom. I've built a stage with, like, curtains and lighting and everything. So if you're standing on my stage in my classroom, you can look down on me.
噢，在我的教室里，我教学生莎士比亚。我们教室里有个舞台。我搭了一个舞台，有幕布、灯光什么的。所以如果你站在我教室的舞台上，你就能俯视我。
Now, you can say that Matthew brought this on himself. He gives some students permission to make fun of him, and he built a stage where students can peer down at him in judgment. But even if he did none of that, he's still a sitting duck for this exact kind of critical gaze.
现在，你可以说这是Matthew自找的。他给了学生嘲笑他的许可，还搭了个舞台让学生居高临下地审视他。但就算他什么都没做，他也依然是这种审视目光下的活靶子。
You have 20 people-- you have 20 students, did you say?
你有20个人——你说有20个学生？
Yeah, it's between 20 and 30 every year.
是的，每年在20到30个之间。
OK, so between 20 and 30 people looking at you all day, every work day, and just taking stock of you.
好的，所以每天、每个工作日都有20到30个人盯着你看，审视着你。
Yes, it's constant. I had pink eye a couple of weeks ago. The kids knew I had pink eye before I did. Because they just stare at you all day, and they see any sort of minute change in you. You know, you're really the only thing they look at for a great majority of the day. So they notice these little things. If I get a new shirt, they immediately notice. Everything that changes about me, they notice right away.
是的，一直如此。几周前我得了红眼病。孩子们比我先发现。因为他们整天盯着你看，能看到你身上任何细微的变化。你知道，在一天中的大部分时间里，你真的是他们唯一看的东西。所以他们会注意到这些小事。如果我换了件新衬衫，他们马上就会注意到。我身上任何改变，他们都会立刻察觉。
Today on the radio show, I, Nancy "Yellow Neck" Updike, bring you stories about people facing the unexpected moment of realizing how other people see them, what that means, and what in God's name to do about it. Today's show-- "Is That What I Look Like"? Prepare to learn the truth. Plus, a special guest appearance that will surprise and delight you. Stay with us.
今天的广播节目，我，Nancy “黄脖子” Updike，带给你们关于人们面对突如其来的时刻，意识到别人如何看待自己、这意味着什么，以及该怎么办的故事。今天的节目——“我看起来是那样吗？”准备好了解真相吧。另外，还有一个会让你们惊喜的特别嘉宾登场。请继续收听。
Act One, Blunt Force. Domingo Martinez has this story about a vision in Brownsville, Texas. Here's Domingo.
第一幕，直击痛点。Domingo Martinez带来了关于德克萨斯州布朗斯维尔的一段幻象。下面是Domingo。
When I was 16, I realized, as far as my family went, school was considered my time, which meant I couldn't be pressed into labor by my father or grandmother. They were farm workers, and they made no claim on my time when I was supposed to be in school. So I learned to take advantage of this. I'd make it to school before 7:30 AM, either by school bus or my mother's Taurus, and then wait out options for escape. By my sophomore year, this kid named Tony Garcia had become my primary friend.
16岁时，我意识到，对我的家庭来说，上学被视为我的“个人时间”，这意味着我父亲或祖母不能强迫我干活。他们是农场工人，但我上学的时候他们不会占用我的时间。所以我学会了利用这一点。我会在早上7:30之前赶到学校，要么坐校车，要么坐我妈的那辆Taurus，然后寻找逃课的机会。到高二时，这个叫Tony Garcia的孩子成了我最好的朋友。
Tony was nearly 19 and only a junior. But he didn't seem all that bad, because he had good parents and an even better little brother who was about to lap him at graduation. Together, Tony and I would find ways to while away the hours by doing anything other than attending class before we had to report home again.
Tony快19岁了，还只是个高二学生。但他看起来并不坏，因为他有很好的父母，还有一个马上就要在毕业时超越他的弟弟。Tony和我总是会想办法消磨时光，只要是不去上课就行，直到我们需要报到回家。
We were big fans of Huckleberry Finn and Tom Sawyer, and we believed we were continuing a long-celebrated American tradition by ditching class and getting stoned-- a fantasy combination of Mark Twain and Hunter S. Thompson. But really, we were just lazy and looking for a good time.
我们是《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》和《汤姆·索亚历险记》的忠实粉丝，我们坚信自己在继承一种悠久的美国传统——通过逃课和吸大麻——这是马克·吐温和亨特·斯托克顿的一种幻想结合。但说实话，我们只是懒，想找点乐子。
The skipping itself was not a problem. The problem was taking care of our grades and absences on our report cards before they reached our parents. And it was actually Tony who initiated me into the trade that I eventually pursued-- graphic design. But in this early stage, in high school, it was plain and simple forgery. There was no design in what we were doing.
逃课本身不是问题。问题在于要在成绩单送达父母手中之前处理好成绩和缺勤。事实上，Tony把我引入了他后来从事的行业——平面设计。但在高中早期阶段，那只是纯粹的伪造。我们所做的一切根本没有设计可言。
It was Tony who placed the first X-Acto knife I ever held in my hands. And immediately, I felt an overwhelming sense of possibility, holding that little penknife. We'd intercept the report cards when they came in the mail. And then, Tony took careful pains to explain this whole process to me, his flunky-- a term that came uncomfortably close to becoming literal-- over the photocopier in the library, feeding dimes into the machine like he was playing slots, in search of a copy that didn't blur or show the incisions in the original.
正是Tony把我手里握的第一把美工刀交给了我。握住那把小刀，我立刻感受到了一种强烈的可能性。邮件寄来成绩单时，我们会拦截下来。然后，Tony不厌其烦地教我这个菜鸟整个过程——这个词用在我们身上简直太贴切了——我们在图书馆的复印机旁，像玩老虎机一样往里投硬币，寻找一张不会模糊、也不会露出原始刀痕的复印件。
Look, man, he said through his trendy and tinted John Lennon glasses-- a wanker style even then. You just got to remove the 2 from the 23 absences and then lighten the reproduction, and now you got 3 absences in first period, instead of 23. Now take the 8 from the 48, move the 4 over, and put the 8 in front of that. And now you have a B in Spanish instead of an F.
看着，伙计，他透过那副时髦的有色约翰·列侬眼镜说——那是种当时看来很装的风格。你只要把23次缺勤里的2去掉，然后调浅复印效果，现在你第一节课就只有3次缺勤了，而不是23次。现在把48里的8拿走，把4移过去，把8放在前面。现在你西班牙语课就是B，而不是F了。
Oh, I said, in total understanding, a big smile growing on my face. Give a man a ride, he skips for a day. Teach him how to forge-- it was ridiculously short-sighted, sure. But at that age, I never thought further than the immediate threat. Simply convincing my mother everything was quiet at school was enough for me. Dealing with school records and the larger consequences of robbing myself of even a substandard education-- all that, I would face at a later date, and certainly have.
哦，我心领神会，脸上绽放出灿烂的笑容。载一个人一程，他逃一天课。教会一个人伪造——这确实目光短浅。但在那个年纪，我从没考虑过眼前的威胁之外的事。只要能让我妈确信学校一切正常，对我来说就够了。至于处理学校记录以及剥夺自己本就不合格的教育所带来的更严重的后果——所有这些，我以后再去面对，事实证明我也确实面对了。
Tony would usually borrow his mother's car for our expeditions-- a blue Oldsmobile Delta 88. We'd leave school and drive to South Padre Island, a resort town at the end of a 28-mile highway that felt much more cosmopolitan than Brownsville, Texas, ever could. We did that drive back and forth, three or four times a day, listening to Led Zeppelin, nodding our heads in unison with whomever else was stoned or drunk in the car.
Tony通常会借他妈妈的车去我们的“探险”——一辆蓝色的奥兹莫比尔Delta 88。我们离开学校，开往南帕德雷岛，那是一个度假小镇，在28英里公路的尽头，感觉比布朗斯维尔国际化多了。我们每天在那条路上往返三四次，听着Led Zeppelin的歌，跟着车里其他嗑药或醉酒的人一起点头。
My junior year and his senior year, Tony's parents bought him a Dodge Daytona. It was the year he would most assuredly graduate, they felt, and it was a chance for him to develop responsibility. In the mornings, the minute my mother would drop me off at school and disappear around the corner, Tony would drive around and park right in front of the school to pick me up, right in front of everybody.
我高二他高三那年，Tony的父母给他买了一辆道奇Daytona。他们觉得那肯定是他会毕业的一年，这是让他培养责任感的机会。每天早上，我妈把我送到学校，车子一转弯消失，Tony就会开车绕过来，停在校门口接我，就在大家眼皮底下。
Dude, you got to come skipping with me today, he'd say. But on one particular morning, late in 1988, I balk. Nah, Tony, I got to go back to class today, I protest. It's Thursday, and I haven't been since last week. Look, he says, I got two signed reentry slips. I can get you back in tomorrow or next week. It's not a problem. And I found a new place to get killer weed. Finding pot was always a problem. So when Tony said he found someone new, and it wasn't one of the morons who hung out by the tennis courts before school, I was intrigued.
伙计，你今天得跟我去逃课，他说。但在1988年年末的一个早上，我退缩了。不了，Tony，我今天得去上课，我抗议道。今天是周四，我从上周起就没去过了。听着，他说，我有两张签了名的返校条。我明天或下周就能帮你弄进去。没问题。而且我找到了个新地方买超棒的草。找大麻总是件麻烦事。所以当Tony说他找到了个新人，而且不是那些在校外网球场鬼混的白痴时，我很感兴趣。
We first drive to a housing project east of school, where a woman sold $2 quarts of Budweiser out of her living room from a cooler to anyone with money, no questions asked. We buy a couple of quarts and smoke the last half-joint Tony has on the way to his new killer weed supplier. I was getting a bit high when I began to recognize the route he was taking, and was then thoroughly taken aback when he drove right into my grandmother's driveway.
我们先开到学校东边的一个廉价住房区，那儿有个女人在客厅里从冷藏箱里卖2美元一夸脱的百威啤酒，只要有钱，什么都不问。我们买了点啤酒，在去他那个新“杀手级大麻”供应商的路上抽完了他剩下的半支烟。我开始有点上头时，才认出他走的路线，然后当他径直开进我祖母的私家车道时，我彻底震惊了。
I couldn't understand why. It just didn't make sense. This was the same driveway my family Pontiac would regularly pull into after church on Sundays when I was growing up in the late 1970s-- my mother's mother's house in downtown Brownsville. I was, I think the term is, "unnerved." My two uncles, Johnny and Abel, were working on a '79 Camaro when Tony drives up and parks hood to hood with their car. The hood was up, and they were both leaning into the guts of the engine.
我不明白为什么。这根本说不通。那是我童年时期（70年代末）每个周日去教堂后，我家那辆庞蒂亚克常停的私家车道——那是布朗斯维尔市中心我外婆的家。我当时，我想那个词叫“惊慌失措”。我的两个舅舅，Johnny和Abel，正在修一辆79年的卡玛洛，Tony开车过来，车头对着他们的车头。引擎盖开着，他们两个都探进引擎里忙活。
Their heads popped up like bearded biker prairie dogs. I sat frozen in the passenger seat, uncertain what to do next. Tony, noticing that I was startled, tells me to be cool, to chill out. These guys look mean, but they're all right. Anyways, he says as he's getting out of the driver's side, they're kind of dumb. But they got great weed. Didn't I know it. Abel and Johnny had a long history with local biker gangs, even a rumored affiliation with the Hell's Angels.
他们的头像长胡子的骑行者草原土拨鼠一样探出来。我坐在副驾驶座上动弹不得，不知所措。Tony察觉到我被吓到了，叫我冷静点，放松。这些人看起来很凶，但他们人不错。反正，他下车时说，他们有点笨。但他们有很棒的草。我能不知道吗。Abel和Johnny在当地骑行帮派里有很长的历史，甚至有传闻说他们和地狱天使有关。
They could get drugs nobody else could in this town. And as a result, they were total burnouts, hardly capable of cogent speech patterns in either English or Spanish. They landed in jail as often as other people attended church. But what they lacked in brains, they certainly made up in brawn. Not that they'd tear apart a teenager like Tony or me, not in the daylight, anyway. They had a code about that sort of thing. But if they felt cheated, they'd have taken a tire iron to my head long before they recognized me as their nephew. They were that burned out.
他们能搞到城里其他人搞不到的毒品。结果，他们彻底废了，几乎连西班牙语或英语的连贯句子都说不出来。他们进监狱的频率和别人去教堂的频率差不多。但他们脑子不行，身体却很壮。并不是说他们会当众把Tony或我撕成碎片，至少在白天不会。他们有那方面的规矩。但如果他们觉得自己被骗了，他们会在认出我是他们外甥之前就用撬胎棒砸我的头。他们就是那样废掉了。
So I sit there, paralyzed, in the front seat, side B of Houses of the Holy playing on Tony's cassette deck. And because it's hot, the AC is blasting. So once Tony closes the door, I can't hear anything. I just watch as this terrifying pantomime plays out before me.
于是我瘫坐在前座，Tony的卡带机里放着《Houses of the Holy》的B面。因为很热，空调开得很大。所以Tony一关车门，我就什么也听不见了。我只能看着这一幕令人恐惧的哑剧在我面前上演。
Tony, half-shaven in his preppy clothes, closes the door and hails his greeting. My uncle Abel, already brain-dead from years of sniffing paint, narrows his eyes in suspicion, and then noiselessly responds with a nodding, hey. Tony averts eye contact, looking anywhere but directly at Abel, for fear that Abel might charge like a gorilla.
Tony穿着考究的校服，刮了一半胡子，关上车门并挥手致意。我舅舅Abel，因为多年吸入油漆早已脑死亡，怀疑地眯起眼睛，然后无声地回以点头示意。Tony避开眼神接触，不敢直视Abel，生怕他像大猩猩一样扑上来。
Abel gives him a suspicious quick upward jut of the chin that says, did I sell to you before? Who told you I got weed? Tony lowers his head in quiet confidence, talking to Abel. Then my uncle Johnny nods towards me in the car, says something to Tony. They all turn to look at me. My eyes go wide, a big smile on my face, nodding. Tony says something, and then they all laugh together. Led Zeppelin still plays loudly in the car.
Abel怀疑地向上抬了抬下巴，意思是：我卖给你过吗？谁告诉你我有草的？Tony低下头，静静地表示自信，跟Abel交流。然后我舅舅Johnny朝我这边点了点头，对Tony说了什么。他们都转头看向我。我眼睛瞪大，脸上挂着大大的笑容，点头。Tony说了句什么，然后他们一起笑了。Led Zeppelin的歌声在车里依旧震天响。
Then, my uncle Abel slaps Tony on the back and leads him around to the back of the car, right where I am. Johnny stands there, too, looking at me and smiling, makes his index finger and thumb into a mock roach, and laughs. I mimic the roach back. Even now, he doesn't recognize me.
接着，Abel舅舅拍了拍Tony的背，带他绕到车后，也就是我坐的位置。Johnny也站在那儿，看着我笑，用食指和大拇指比出一个模拟抽烟的手势，然后笑了。我也比了个同样的手势回过去。直到现在，他都没认出我。
Then, Tony and Abel emerge around the other side of the car with Tony's hand in his pocket, and both of them are laughing like they're suddenly old friends. Tony turns and waves, and both Johnny and Abel wave back. The door opens, and Tony says, dude, we got a big joint for 2 bucks, as he gets in the driver's seat. This has freaked me out to no end. Abel and Johnny are both waving, making the universal roach smoking signal as we drive off. And it leaves me feeling really, really conflicted.
接着，Tony和Abel从车另一边走过来，Tony的手放在口袋里，两人笑得像老友重逢。Tony转头挥手，Johnny和Abel也挥手回礼。车门开了，Tony一边坐进驾驶座一边说，伙计，我们用2块钱买了一大支。这让我吓得不轻。Abel和Johnny都在挥手，做着通用的抽烟手势，我们驱车离开。这让我感到非常非常矛盾。
The car slips up the southernmost terminus of Highway 77, and we head north from urban Brownsville to drive around as we smoke the joint. Tony lights it, and it starts burning purple. Purple haze, he says, and then follows it with his characteristic, aah!
车滑上77号公路的最南端，我们向北驶离布朗斯维尔市区，一边开车一边抽那支烟。Tony点燃它，烟雾开始发出紫色的光。紫雾，他说，接着是他标志性的，啊！
Hey, man, I say, I'm kind of scared about smoking this. I've never seen one burn this color. Aw, dude, says Tony, don't worry about it. Those guys got killer weed, man. They're like bikers or something. It's probably laced with something. That's why it was 2 bucks.
嘿，伙计，我说，我有点害怕抽这个。我从没见过烟是这种颜色的。噢，伙计，Tony说，别担心。那些人有杀手级大麻。他们是什么骑行者之类的。这可能掺了什么东西。所以才只要2块钱。
This idea sounds appealing to Tony. It scares the shit out of me. We're both getting incredibly high. Hey, man, says Tony, wouldn't it be messed up if, like, when you were high, your hair went into a huge orange Afro, and the higher you were, the bigger your Afro got? You couldn't go anywhere, because people would be like, man, that guy's stoned.
这个想法对Tony来说很刺激。却把我吓坏了。我们俩都变得非常兴奋。嘿，伙计，Tony说，如果人在嗑药时，头发会变成巨大的橙色爆炸头，而且越嗨爆炸头就越大，那岂不是很糟？你哪儿也去不了，因为人们会说，天哪，那哥们嗑大了。
I sit there in Tony's car and think about my uncles Johnny and Abel. Johnny had been stabbed in the back with a flatheaded screwdriver about a month earlier in a street fight. His lung had been punctured, and my grandmother said you could hear whistling every time he inhaled. He wouldn't go to the hospital to get it treated for three days.
我坐在Tony的车里，想着我的舅舅Johnny和Abel。Johnny一个月前在一场街头斗殴中背部被人用平头螺丝刀捅伤。他的肺被刺穿了，我祖母说每次他呼吸时都能听到哨声。他三天没去医院处理。
We're halfway done with the joint when I say to Tony, hey, man, I don't want to get stoned anymore. All right, well, put it out, Tony says, nodding his head back and forth to Zeppelin. Tony's left hand is fingering chords into the neck of an imaginary guitar as he's driving. I watch his fingers move for a few seconds, suspended and twisting around like they're an overturned king crab. And I can find no correlation with the chords in the song.
我们快要把烟抽完时，我对Tony说，嘿，伙计，我不想再嗑药了。好吧，那就把它灭了，Tony说，跟着Zeppelin的音乐不停点头。Tony的左手在开车时还在空气中指弹着假想吉他的弦。我盯着他的手指移动了几秒，它们悬空扭动着，就像翻过来的大王蟹。我完全找不出那跟歌里的和弦有什么关系。
Man, I mean, I don't want to smoke pot anymore, I say to him. I don't want to skip class anymore. I want to get back to school. Not today, but, like, in general. I don't want to feel like this anymore, like I'm doing something bad. I feel like this all the time now. Dirty.
伙计，我是说，我不想再抽大麻了，我对他说。我不想再逃课了。我想回学校。不是今天，而是，总的来说。我不想再有这种感觉了，像是我在做坏事。我一直有这种感觉。脏兮兮的。
Look at that really [BLEEP] small house over there. We were on an overpass, and I just noticed a house beneath us in the Brownsville country club, about a 1/4 of the size of the houses surrounding it. Tony starts laughing so hard, I have to make him focus back on the driving.
看看那边那个真的[消音]小的房子。我们当时正在立交桥上，我注意到桥下布朗斯维尔乡村俱乐部里有一栋房子，只有周围房子1/4的大小。Tony笑得太大声了，我不得不让他重新专注于开车。
But then, I laugh along with him. You're stoned, he tells me. Yeah, I say, I'm way stoned. Hey, man, I say a little later. We're driving back to South Padre Island now. You know those guys we bought weed from earlier today? The bikers? Tony says. That was my grandmother's house, man. Those were my uncles, I say, even though I'm really embarrassed by it. Tony finds this befuddling. He can't figure out what the bikers were doing at my grandmother's house.
但后来，我也跟着他笑了。你嗑大了，他告诉我。是啊，我说，我真的嗑大了。嘿，伙计，过了一会儿我说。我们现在正开回南帕德雷岛。你知道我们今天早些时候在那儿买草的人吗？那些骑行者？Tony说。那是我外婆的家，伙计。那是我的舅舅们，我说，尽管我为此感到非常尴尬。Tony对此感到困惑。他想不通那些骑行者为什么在我外婆家。
Those dudes were my mom's brothers, man, my uncles, I explain. Tony is laughing so hard, he has to pull over to the side of the road. His laughing is infectious, and I find myself laughing right along with him, laughing harder than I have laughed in a really, really long time. But I'm feeling utterly beyond redemption on the inside, like I'd just done something today that I couldn't take back, like my course was now set.
那些家伙是我妈的兄弟，伙计，是我的舅舅们，我解释说。Tony笑得太厉害，不得不把车停到路边。他的笑声会传染，我也发现自己跟着他一起笑，笑得比我很久很久以来笑得都要厉害。但在内心深处，我感到一种彻底的不可救药，就像我今天做了一件无法挽回的事，就像我的人生轨道已经定型了。
Domingo Martinez, reading a story from his memoir, The Boy Kings of Texas.
Domingo Martinez，朗读他回忆录《德克萨斯男孩之王》中的一个片段。
Act Two, Not My First Time at the Rodeo. Parents and children are lifelong mirrors for each other. How do you see me? How do I see myself through my relationship with you? Even when you're not face to face with one of your parents, there are conversations between you that play back in your head your whole life-- what they said, what you said. Sometimes you repeat those conversations to explain to someone else or to yourself who you are or who your parents are.
第二幕，老手。父母和子女是一面终身的镜子。你如何看待我？透过和你关系，我是如何看待自己的？即使没有和父母面对面，你脑海里也终身回荡着你们之间的对话——他们说了什么，你说了什么。有时你重复那些对话，是为了向别人或向自己解释你是谁，或者是你的父母是谁。
But what if you could rehear the actual dialogue decades later-- not your memory of it but the words that were truly spoken between you and a parent? A while back, I did a story about someone who got that exact chance. Bill Lahey was in his early 20s and on the phone with his father in 1978 when he heard a faint pinging sound on the phone. He mentioned it, and his father said--
但如果你能在几十年后重新听到真实的对话呢——不是你的记忆，而是你和父母之间真正说出口的话？前阵子，我做了一个关于有人获得这个机会的故事。Bill Lahey在1978年20出头时，正和父亲通电话，突然听到电话里有细微的“砰砰”声。他提到了，他父亲说——
When did that start?
那是什么时候开始的？
It's been there all along.
一直都有。
I never heard it.
我从没听到过。
No?
没吗？
Must be my bad ear.
肯定是我耳朵不好。
Just a ping, like, every five seconds.
就只是砰的一声，大概每五秒钟一次。
That's funny.
真有趣。
Yeah.
是啊。
Maybe we're, uh, being eavesdropped on.
也许我们，呃，正被窃听呢。
Monitored or something?
被监控什么的？
Huh? (CHUCKLING) Yeah. Sometimes I wonder if this phone is tapped.
哈？（笑）是啊。有时候我怀疑这电话被监听了。
Two decades later, after his father had died, Bill was at his dad's house in Ohio, cleaning out the office.
二十年后，在他父亲去世后，Bill在他父亲位于俄亥俄州的家中清理办公室。
And I opened up a file cabinet and found 30 or 40 cassette tapes with his unmistakable handwritten notations of names and dates. And I knew instantly what they were, that he had been surreptitiously taping us.
我打开一个档案柜，发现了三四十盘磁带，上面有他那标志性的、手写的名字和日期标注。我立刻知道它们是什么，他一直在偷偷录我们的音。
Even at the time his father was recording, Bill had guessed what could be going on. It was the kind of thing his father might do. And he did. He recorded hours of calls with Bill. And according to his own handwritten labels, he also taped his four other children, his wife, his mother, other relatives, his priest. He recorded calls at home and in the car.
即使在他父亲录音时，Bill也猜到可能发生了什么。这是他父亲可能会做的那种事。他也确实做了。他录下了和Bill通话的几小时录音。根据他自己的手写标签，他还录了他其他四个孩子、妻子、母亲、其他亲戚和牧师的通话。他在家里和车里都录了音。
Recording test number four. Road noise, average to low. Speed, 60 miles an hour.
录音测试四。路噪，中等到低。车速，每小时60英里。
From the dates on the cassettes, Bill figured they were an archive of his father, trying to get the people around him onto his side. Bill's mother had left his father after 37 years of marriage. Bill remembered the gist and tone of those conversations pretty well. They were memorable.
从磁带的日期来看，Bill推断出这些是他父亲的档案，试图让周围的人站在他这边。Bill的母亲在37年的婚姻后离开了他父亲。Bill还清楚地记得那些谈话的梗概和语气。它们让人难忘。
And he put off listening to the recordings of them. For 12 years, they sat in a black nylon duffel bag that he would move every time the family moved. This was a pile of information Bill wasn't sure he wanted, from an era of his life he knew he didn't want to relive.
他一直推迟听那些录音。12年来，它们一直装在一个黑色尼龙行李袋里，每次搬家他都会带着。这是一堆Bill不确定自己是否想要的关于他人生某个阶段的信息，那个阶段他不想重温。
He'd sided with his mom in the divorce, even before the divorce. Since junior high, he'd been lobbying her to leave his dad. As Bill saw his father, he was smart, tenacious, and a tremendous bully with a bad, quick temper and huge blowups.
他在离婚案中站在母亲这边，甚至在离婚前就是如此。从初中起，他就一直在游说母亲离开他父亲。在Bill眼中，他父亲聪明、顽强，但也是一个脾气暴躁、爱发火、动不动就大吼大叫的霸凌者。
He got worse over time, and he was worse when he drank. What Bill remembered from the taped conversations were long calls where his father bullied him and he fought back hard. He saw himself as his mother's advocate and protector.
随着时间推移他变本加厉，喝酒时更糟糕。Bill从这些录音里记得的是他父亲长时间对他进行言语霸凌，而他顽强反击。他视自己为母亲的倡导者和保护者。
I remember him trying to recruit me in his campaign to keep his marriage together. And so my memory was me saying versions of, look, she doesn't want to do that anymore. You guys have tried for a long time. Let it go. (CHUCKLING) You know, some version of, face facts, it's over.
我记得他试图拉拢我加入他的阵营，好维持他的婚姻。所以我的记忆是我在说些类似版本的话，比如，看，她不想再那样了。你们已经努力很久了。放手吧。（笑）你知道，就是那种，面对现实吧，一切都结束了。
So you remember pushing back verbally, arguing with him.
所以你记得自己曾言语回击，跟他争论。
Yeah. Yeah. All the time.
是啊。是啊。一直都在。
After those 12 years of holding on to the tapes, Bill finally reached just about the age his father had been when he'd made the recordings. And suddenly, Bill wanted to hear them. He felt ready but nervous.
在保留这些磁带12年后，Bill终于到了他父亲录音时的年纪。突然，他想听听它们了。他感到准备好了，但也感到紧张。
Here was raw data about what I actually did in conversations with my dad. And I just took one of the tapes with me-- has my name on it-- and went into our car in the back of our house, partially because it was the only place that had a cassette tape recorder that I knew of. And the first thing that came on was his voice, pretty aggressively questioning me about something. And his voice was as clear as the day I heard it.
这里有关于我在和父亲谈话时究竟做了什么的原始数据。我随手拿了盘磁带——上面写着我的名字——走到我们房子后面的一辆车里，部分原因是因为我知道那里有台盒式录音机。放出的第一件事就是他的声音，相当咄咄逼人地询问我某件事。他的声音像我听到那天一样清晰。
So you got pretty involved there, didn't you, for somebody who didn't want to take sides?
所以你陷得很深，不是吗，对于一个不想选边站的人来说？
Yeah, I did.
是的，我陷进去了。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
I certainly did.
我确实是。
His father was talking about the fact that Bill and his four siblings all sided with their mother in the divorce, in one way or another.
他父亲在谈论Bill和他的四个兄弟姐妹在离婚这件事上，以某种方式都站在了母亲一边。
So why did you do it? What, were you feeling sorry for your mother?
那你们为什么要这么做？什么，你在为母亲感到难过吗？
No.
不是。
For being oppressed? You'd think she was going around in a wheelchair. How would you feel, Bill? And have that kind of a situation where, you know, the mother hen's being protected-- from who? She's got everybody believing that I'm a goddamn bully. She's so psychotic, because she's got everybody believing that I'm a bastard. That's how psychotic she is. How would you feel if you were me, Bill?
为她受压迫？你还以为她得坐轮椅呢。Bill，你感觉如何？在这种情况下，你知道，母鸡被保护着——从谁那儿保护？她让所有人都相信我是个该死的霸凌者。她简直疯了，因为她让所有人都相信我是个混蛋。她就是这么疯。如果换作是你，Bill，你会怎么想？
And I listened for, probably, two minutes. And I was like, OK. (LAUGHING) That's what they are. This is just really intense. I put-- took the tape out, went back and went into the house, told my wife about it, and didn't listen to them again for, I don't know, three or four months.
我听了大概两分钟。我当时想，好吧。（笑）原来是这样。这简直太强烈了。我把磁带拿出来，回到屋里，告诉了妻子，然后三四个月没再听过。
When Bill went back to listening for real, what he heard was his father pushing one main point with him, hour after hour, which was, how about you talking your mother into trying again?
当Bill真正开始听时，他听到父亲一小时又一小时地向他强调一个重点，那就是，你要不要劝你母亲再试一次？
How do you feel about that assessment?
你对这个评估感觉如何？
To give it a try?
试一次？
Yeah.
对。
[SIGHS] Well-- just from talking to Mother over the months, um, I've seen really no sign of changing her mind or--
[叹气] 嗯……根据几个月来和母亲的谈话，嗯，我真的没看到她有任何回心转意的迹象，或者……
Well, has anybody really tried to, Bill, forcibly, persuasively? Is it fair that she doesn't try, whether she wants to or not? And the answer, obviously, is, no, it isn't fair. To have to go down the drain and lose the war for a few battles without trying is, to me, absurd.
那么，Bill，有人真正试过吗，强有力地、有说服力地？如果她不想试，那就不试，这公平吗？答案显然是不公平。在还没尝试之前就输掉战争，对我来说是荒谬的。
Yeah. Well, I guess because I see more than just a few battles.
是啊。好吧，我想那是因为我看到的不仅仅是几次战斗。
All right, so there was a bunch of them. What the hell is the difference? There were a lot of good times. Why do you look at the black part?
好吧，所以有很多次。这到底有什么区别？过去有很多美好时光。为什么你只看阴暗面？
Well, Dad, because I didn't see that time that things were-- worked well. Not-- I mean, maybe when I was very young.
好吧，爸爸，因为我没看到那些时间事情进展得……顺利。没……我是说，也许在我很小的时候。
You mean you had no remembrance-- we had no happiness, Bill?
你是说你毫无记忆——我们之间没有任何快乐吗，Bill？
I didn't say none. I mean, but--
我没说没有。我是说，但是……
You just said you never saw the times when we did.
你刚才说你从没见过我们快乐的时候。
A period. I mean, when-- a period when I'd say things were just generally--
有一段时间。我是说，当……有一段时间，我会说一切都……很正常。
Oh, you have a short memory, Bill. I'm sorry to say that. We used to go up to Lake Erie. We had a lot of good times. You know--
噢，你的记性真短，Bill。很遗憾这么说。我们过去常去伊利湖。我们有很多美好时光。你知道……
I'm not saying we didn't, but--
我不是说我们没有，但是……
Bill, are you saying that there's no use trying?
Bill，你是说尝试也没用吗？
I'm not saying that. I just--
我不是那个意思。我只是……
What's the bottom line? Let's get down to it. This is a lot of conversation. Tell me what your attitude is. Are you advocating that we don't try?
底线是什么？让我们言归正传吧。这聊了很久了。告诉我你的态度。你是主张我们不要尝试吗？
I'm just-- I'm just taking--
我只是……我只是在采取……
No, I want to know. Why do you take so long to answer?
不，我想知道。为什么你回答得这么慢？
Kind of like, say something. (LAUGHING) Like, you know, just don't sit there. I was less confrontational than I remember or expected. But I could remember that thought process that I went through. If I say x, he's going to blow up. If I say y, I'm going to throw my mom under the bus.
有点像，说点什么。（笑）就像，你知道，别就坐在那儿。我并没有像我记忆或预期的那样爱对抗。但我能记起我当时经历的思维过程。如果我说x，他会爆发。如果我说y，我会把我妈卖了。
I just-- I know what Mother's-- at least from what she tells me she's-- this has been something that she's obviously been thinking about a long time.
我只是……我知道母亲的……至少从她告诉我的情况来看，她是……这显然是她考虑了很久的事情。
Not-- not no long time. Maybe four or five years. Bill, do you know that her mind might be affected and she may not be herself psychologically?
没……不是很久。也许四五年了。Bill，你知道她的精神可能受到了影响，她在心理上可能不是她自己了吗？
For four or five years?
四五年了？
Bill, do you realize that her mind might be affected? She may not be herself psychologically?
Bill，你意识到她的精神可能受到了影响吗？她在心理上可能不是她自己了吗？
For that long of time?
持续那么久吗？
Yes. Would you like to see-- see us happy if we can arrange to be together?
是的。如果我们可以安排在一起，你想看到……看到我们幸福吗？
Sure.
当然。
Why don't you say that?
你为什么不直接说出来？
Where was the warrior in me? Where was the standup person that was willing to call a lie a lie, willing to draw bright lines, and say, I'm not-- I won't even put up with having a conversation about this?
我身体里的战士在哪儿？那个敢于直言不讳、愿意划清界限、说我不会忍受这种谈话的站得住脚的人在哪儿？
And some of these conversations go on so long. I mean, 45 minutes, an hour, and he's just hammering away at you and at the points he's making. Why did you stay on such a long time? Why not just say, you know, Dad, I got to go?
而且其中一些对话持续得太久了。我是说，45分钟，一个小时，他只是不停地敲打着你和他提出的观点。你为什么坚持那么久？为什么不直接说，你知道，爸爸，我得走了？
Yeah, no, I-- I mean, I was-- so I was living in Wisconsin during a lot of this taping. I felt badly that my mom was back there, basically, by herself, dealing with him. And I think I had some notion that by staying on the phone with him, you know, it's like a little bit of the rodeo clown. You know, those old rodeo clowns would be sent out. The cowboy would be bucked off the bull. And those rodeo clowns--
是的，不，我……我是说，我……在这些录音的大部分时间里，我住在威斯康星州。我很难过我妈妈独自一人在那儿面对他。我想我有一种想法，通过留在电话上和他聊天，你知道，有点像竞技场上的小丑。你知道，那些老牛仔竞技表演的小丑会被派上去。牛仔会被牛甩下来。而那些小丑……
To distract the bull?
去分散牛的注意力？
--would go out to distract the bull.
……会跑出去分散那头牛的注意力。
Bill wasn't crushed by the difference between what he heard on the tapes and the tough line he'd remembered taking with his dad. But it did throw him off balance. He really had seen himself, from the time he was a kid, as a warrior, standing up to the strong, protecting the weak, a sort of superhero, when it came to arguing against his dad.
Bill并没有被他在录音中听到的对话与他记忆中对父亲采取的强硬立场之间的差距所压垮。但这确实让他失去了平衡。从孩提时代起，他就真正视自己为一名战士，能够挺身对抗强者，保护弱者，在反对父亲的争论中表现得像个超级英雄。
But I was less heroic. It was like I was more pragmatic. It was less of an epic struggle of right and wrong and more mundane than that.
但我并没有那么英勇。这感觉更务实。这与其说是一场关于对错的史诗斗争，不如说是平庸得多。
I mean, what kid fantasizes about being a pragmatist?
我是说，哪个孩子会幻想自己成为一个务实主义者呢？
[LAUGHS] Right.
[笑] 也对。
Bill says his mother thrived after the divorce. His father, he says, stayed more or less the same. He married again, divorced again. Bill kept up a relationship with him his whole life. That had been his other goal during these calls, besides protecting his mom-- not losing his dad.
Bill说他母亲在离婚后生活得很幸福。他说，他父亲多多少少还是老样子。他又结了婚，又离了婚。Bill一生都和他保持着联系。除了保护母亲之外，那是他在这些通话中的另一个目标——不要失去父亲。
He had thought about that even during the worst arguments. Better a long silence than words he couldn't take back. Bill saw his father once or twice a year, every year, after the divorce. And he spoke to him by phone every few weeks until he died.
即使在最糟糕的争吵中他也曾这样想过。沉默总比说出无法收回的话要好。离婚后，Bill每年见父亲一两次。直到他去世，他每隔几周就通过电话和他交谈。
I'll call you back soon. You could call me in the evening.
我很快会再打给你。你可以晚上打给我。
Your number's the same?
你的号码还是没变吧？
Sure.
当然。
All right.
好吧。
Any time you want to chat.
你想聊天的时候随时打。
All right.
好的。
OK. So I will talk to you soon.
行。那我很快会跟你谈。
OK, I'm glad you called.
好的，很高兴你打给我。
Yeah.
是啊。
Take care.
保重。
OK, Dad. Good night.
好的，爸爸。晚安。
Coming up-- what the movie The Breakfast Club can teach you about parenting if you were in The Breakfast Club. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来——如果你曾是《早餐俱乐部》的一员，电影《早餐俱乐部》能教会你什么育儿之道。一分钟后，《美国生活》继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Nancy Updike, sitting in for Ira Glass. Every week, we choose a theme. You know that. And we present various stories on that theme.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Nancy Updike，代班Ira Glass。每周我们都会选择一个主题。你知道的。我们针对那个主题呈现各种各样的故事。
Today's show-- "Is That What I Look Like?" Stories of seeing yourself through other people's eyes, whether you want to or not. And we're here at Act Three, which I think is going to be kind of a two-parter. Act Three-- Ben, do you want to do that part?
今天的节目——“我看起来是那样吗？”关于透过他人的眼睛看待自己的故事，不管你想不想。我们来到了第三幕，我觉得这将是一个两部分的故事。第三幕——Ben，你想讲那部分吗？
Sure. Act Three, The Blunder Years.
当然。第三幕，青涩岁月。
I'm talking to Ben Calhoun, one of the producers here. And he's got a small story. He's embarrassed to tell it, but I'm making him. So Ben.
我正在和Ben Calhoun交谈，我们这里的制作人之一。他有个小故事。他不好意思讲，但我非逼着他讲。所以，Ben。
Yeah?
是吗？
Take us back. It's eighth grade?
带我们回去。是八年级？
Eighth grade. And I should just say, like, I played tuba. I was small. That was me. And definitely, like, zero attention from the girls in Roosevelt Middle School.
八年级。我得说，我是吹大号的。我个子小。那就是我。而且绝对是，在那所罗斯福中学里，女生对我是零关注。
I had this teacher, though, who-- her name was Miss Savage. She was the cool teacher.
不过我有位老师——她叫Savage小姐。她是那个酷老师。
I bet.
我打赌。
Yeah. She was younger than, like, pretty much every teacher in the school. She was, like, into Jane's Addiction, and she was, like, the rock-and-roll teacher, and all of the kids sort of, like, idolized her.
是啊。她比学校里几乎所有老师都年轻。她喜欢简的嗜好乐队（Jane's Addiction），她是那种摇滚老师，所有的孩子都崇拜她。
OK, and we are going in a G/PG direction with this, right? Just checking.
好吧，我们要往家长指导级方向走，对吧？我确认一下。
(LAUGHING) Yeah.
（笑）是啊。
OK.
好的。
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是啊。[笑]
Continue.
继续。
So there was just this one day when I'm just, like, standing in the classroom, and there was, like, a-- there was, like, a crowd of girls that were standing around Miss Savage. And I don't-- I have no idea what they were talking about.
有一天，我正站在教室里，有一群女生正围着Savage小姐。我不知道她们在谈论什么。
And Miss Savage is, like, saying something, and then, out of the blue, she says-- and she points to me. Like, I'm standing on the other side of the room, and she says, look out for that Ben Calhoun. He's going to be a heartbreaker.
Savage小姐正说着什么，突然，她指着我。我当时站在教室的另一边，她说，小心那个Ben Calhoun。他会是个伤透女人心的家伙。
And did the girls turn and look?
那些女生转过头来看了吗？
It was like a crowd of faces pivoted like satellites and looked at me. And I was just like, I don't-- I don't totally know what happened, but it feels like maybe my life might have changed just right then. [LAUGHS]
就像一群卫星一样，所有的面孔转向我。我当时就想，我不知道发生了什么，但感觉就像我的生活就在那一刻改变了。[笑]
And?
然后呢？
You mean, like, what--
你是说，什么……
Did it change? Yeah. Yeah, did the girls kind of start to notice?
它改变了吗？是啊，是啊，女生们开始注意你了吗？
One girl in particular.
有一个女孩特别注意。
That's all you need.
这就够了。
Yeah.
是啊。
And that really can be all you need to change your life when you're a teenager-- just one person who thinks you're great. Because chances are, your own sense of yourself is way off. A friend of a friend-- this is a woman in her 50s-- came across an old photo of herself as a teenager.
当你是青少年时，那真的就是改变你人生所需要的一切——只要有一个人觉得你很棒。因为很有可能，你对自己本身的评价完全错了。一个朋友的朋友——一位50多岁的女性——偶然看到了她十几岁时的一张老照片。
And it had been years since she'd seen any pictures of herself at that age. And she looked at them and thought, oh, wait, I was pretty. I was pretty. It kind of floored her. Because of course, the girl in the pictures looked nothing like the way she thought of herself at the time. She said she wished she'd known it back then. It would have made a difference.
她已经很多年没见过自己那个年纪的照片了。她看着它们想，噢，等等，我当时挺漂亮的。这让她感到惊呆了。因为当然，照片里的女孩和她当时的自我认知完全不一样。她说她真希望那时就知道。那会带来很大的改变。
Lots of us have had that experience-- looking at old family pictures or yearbooks, seeing things we never saw at the time. This next story is a very specialized case of that kind of thing. It's about the actress Molly Ringwald, who, of course, doesn't just have photos, but movies, beautifully shot, widescreen, full-length Hollywood films of herself as a teenager.
我们很多人都有过这种经历——看着老家庭照片或年鉴，看到当时从未意识到的东西。下一个故事是一个非常特别的案例。关于女演员Molly Ringwald，当然，她不仅仅有照片，还有电影，宽屏、长篇的好莱坞电影，记录了她十几岁时的样子。
She's the redhead, the star, in those three iconic '80s movies by John Hughes-- Pretty in Pink, Sixteen Candles, and The Breakfast Club. Recently, she revisited one of those movies, not exactly by choice, and she talked to Ira Glass. Here's Ira.
她就是John Hughes执导的那三部80年代经典电影——《粉红佳人》、《十六支蜡烛》和《早餐俱乐部》里的那个红发明星。最近，她重看了其中一部，并不是心甘情愿，她和Ira Glass聊了聊。下面是Ira。
I suppose it's not a big surprise that Molly Ringwald does not sit around watching old Molly Ringwald films. You know, she's seen 'em. She needs a big reason to go back to them.
我想 Molly Ringwald 不会闲着没事重看老电影，这并不奇怪。你知道，她看过。她需要一个很大的理由才会回去看。
And recently, her daughter gave her a reason. Her daughter, Mathilda, is 10. And Mathilda wanted to see The Breakfast Club. Of course, 10 is a little young to see The Breakfast Club, but most of her friends had seen it.
最近，她女儿给了她一个理由。她的女儿Mathilda，10岁。Mathilda想看《早餐俱乐部》。当然，10岁看《早餐俱乐部》有点小，但她的朋友大多都看过。
So it was kind of weird that she was the only one that hadn't seen this movie. And she said that it was a conversation at slumber parties where that's a movie that some kids want to watch, and that she had always said, plea-- I don't want to watch it. Can we watch something else? Because she wanted to watch it with me, which I thought was really nice.
所以她是唯一没看过这部电影的人，这有点奇怪。她说在睡衣派对上，这是有些孩子想看的电影，而她总是说，拜托……我不想看。我们能看别的吗？因为她想跟我一起看，我觉得这真的很贴心。
I wonder if it's like she wants to watch it with you-- like, that's a nice thing to say to your mom. But the truth could also be, she just doesn't want to watch it with them. You know what I mean? Like, can you imagine watching your mom with a group of your friends, like, and you have no idea what's about to happen?
我不知道这是不是因为她想跟你一起看——那是一个女儿对妈妈说的好听的话。但真相也可能是，她只是不想跟她们一起看。你懂我的意思吗？比如，你能想象和一群朋友一起看你妈吗，然后你根本不知道会发生什么？
Yeah. I didn't even really think about that, but yeah, I'm sure that had something to do with it. Mathilda does not like surprises.
是啊。我甚至没往那方面想，但是的，我肯定这有一定关系。Mathilda不喜欢意外。
And the fact is, Molly Ringwald preferred to watch it with Mathilda. It just seemed like it might be a nice experience to share together. And there were things in the film that she knew that she was going to want to talk to Mathilda about. Like, for instance, there's a scene where she smokes pot in the film as a teenager.
事实是，Molly Ringwald更愿意和Mathilda一起看。这看起来是一个值得分享的美好体验。而且电影里有一些她知道她会想和Mathilda谈论的事情。例如，电影里有一个她十几岁时抽大麻的场景。
So Molly showed her The Breakfast Club, not sure at all how she was going to react, not sure what it would be like to see the film through Mathilda's eyes. We sent her a tape recorder to record what happened.
所以Molly给她看了《早餐俱乐部》，完全不确定她会有什么反应，不确定透过Mathilda的眼睛看这部电影会是什么感觉。我们送给她一台录音机，记录下了过程。
Hello.
你好。
Which, by the way, Mathilda loved the tape recorder.
顺便说一句，Mathilda很喜欢那台录音机。
Hello. So--
你好。所以……
She loved talking into the tape recorder. She loved answering questions-- though she is not going to hear this radio story for a long time. That's the plan. The Breakfast Club, if you've never seen, is five kids. They're stuck together in school on a Saturday, for all-day detention.
她喜欢对着录音机说话。她喜欢回答问题——尽管她很久都不会听到这个广播故事。那是计划。如果你从没看过，《早餐俱乐部》是五个孩子的故事。他们在周六被困在学校里接受全天禁闭。
They're kids who never would normally talk to each other in school. It's a jock, a brain, a tough kid, a popular girl, and an outsider girl. And you know, it's a John Hughes movie. They bond, talking about all these things that everybody feels in high school.
他们是平时在学校绝不会交谈的孩子。一个运动员、一个书呆子、一个叛逆少年、一个人气女孩和一个局外女孩。你知道，这是一部John Hughes的电影。他们建立了联系，谈论每个人在高中都会有的那种感觉。
And you can totally see why it still gets to kids and why it's the John Hughes film that Molly Ringwald looks back on as her favorite. So she and Mathilda-- they make popcorn. They futz around with the TV.
你可以完全理解为什么它依然能触动孩子，为什么它是Molly Ringwald最喜欢回首的John Hughes电影。所以她和Mathilda——她们做了爆米花。她们折腾电视机。
And you know, stars are just like us. They do not know how to operate their video systems either. They cannot figure out how to turn it on, and is it DVD or HDMI?
而且你知道，明星也跟我们一样。她们也不知道怎么操作视频系统。她们搞不懂怎么打开它，到底是DVD还是HDMI？
HDM1-2?
HDMI-2吗？
It's HDMI.
是HDMI。
I mean, it sounds really silly. I mean, it's like, it was almost like a date, you know? Like, where you just-- you just want everything to go OK.
我是说，这听起来真的很傻。我觉得，这就像是一次约会，你知道吗？你就是……你就是希望一切顺利。
Yeah.
是啊。
You know? I didn't want her to-- I didn't want her to not like it, you know? I didn't want her to get bored.
你知道吗？我不希望她……不希望她不喜欢它，你知道。我不希望她觉得无聊。
OK. Wait.
好吧。等等。
OK, it's fun to talk to-- ah! You! Oh, my god, it's you!
好了，跟……啊！是你！天哪，是你！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Was there any point during the film where you had second thoughts about watching it with her?
在电影过程中，有没有哪个瞬间你对和她一起看产生过后悔？
The sex stuff, I was a little-- I was cringing a little bit.
性相关的部分，我有点……我有点尴尬。
Oh, are you medically frigid or is it psychological?
噢，你是生理上冷淡还是心理上冷淡？
I didn't mean it that way! You guys are putting words in my mouth!
我不是那个意思！你们这些家伙在断章取义！
You know, there's a whole part where everyone is saying, did you do it? Did you do it?
你知道，电影里有一整段，每个人都在说，你做了吗？你做了吗？
Why don't you just answer the question?
你为什么不直接回答这个问题？
Be honest.
诚实点。
It's no big deal.
这没什么大不了的。
Yeah, answer it.
是啊，回答吧。
Just answer the question, Claire.
回答这个问题，Claire。
Talk to us.
跟我们谈谈。
Come on.
来吧。
Answer the question.
回答问题。
So then, I'm thinking, she's going to ask me, what are they talking about? But then, she just didn't ask. It was-- she was not-- all of that stuff, she just didn't want to know. And so I was trying to sort of ask her what she got out of that, what she thought we were talking about, but trying to ask her in such a way where I wouldn't tell her, where I wouldn't end up talking about sex if she didn't know. So all the talk about, did she do it, did she not do it, all of that stuff, kind of--
所以那时我心想，她会问我，她们在谈论什么？但她只是没问。她当时……她不是——所有那些事，她只是不想知道。所以我试着问她从中得到了什么，她觉得我们在谈论什么，但试着用一种不会告诉她、不会导致我们谈论性的话题的方式。所以关于“她做了吗，她没做吗”的所有谈论，那种东西……
The what-- the what part?
什么——什么部分？
When they were like, did you do it? Did you do it? Claire, just answer the question. Answer the question.
当她们像那样问的时候，你做了吗？你做了吗？Claire，回答这个问题。回答问题。
Wait, which part? They were-- what?
等等，哪部分？她们——什么？
And my husband's sitting there, looking at me, just, stop. Stop. She doesn't get it.
我丈夫坐在那里看着我，只是，停下。停下。她听不懂。
So this is the first time that you saw the film as a parent.
所以这是你第一次以母亲的身份观看这部电影。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Did you see it differently?
你看到的不同吗？
Absolutely. I really did. Like, I really kind of felt for the parents.
当然。我真的感觉到了。就像，我真的很同情父母。
For people who haven't seen The Breakfast Club, a lot of it is about the kids being disappointed in the parents.
对于那些没看过《早餐俱乐部》的人，其中很大一部分是关于孩子们对父母感到失望。
Yeah, and how alone and isolated and frustrated you feel with your parents. And now, I see the movie, and I just-- I think, oh, their poor parents. And I think that when it was pointed out to me that the movie just talks about how all parents suck, you know, then I thought in my mind, well, actually, that might be kind of good, because then she can see that she doesn't have parents like that. And then, she can appreciate us. [LAUGHS] And--
是啊，以及你在父母面前感到多么孤独、孤立和挫败。而现在，我重看这部电影，我只是……我心想，噢，可怜的父母们。而且我觉得当有人向我指出这部电影只是在谈论所有的父母都很烂时，你知道，我想，嗯，实际上，这可能是一件好事，因为那样她就能看到她并没有那样的父母。然后，她可以感激我们。[笑] 而且……
You know, but that can go another way.
你知道，但这可能会有另一种后果。
Yeah, that was my focus, I guess.
是的，我想那是我的关注点。
OK, so afterwards, you're talking to her about the film, and there's this moment that gets surprisingly emotional. And let me play you that.
好的，所以后来，你在和她谈论这部电影，有个时刻出人意料地情绪化。让我放给你听听那个。
Which character, when the characters talk, and you think, like, oh, that's what I feel like? Are there any that you say, like, yeah, that's like what I feel like?
哪个角色，当角色们交谈时，你觉得，噢，那种感觉跟我一样？有没有哪个让你觉得，对，那就像我的感觉？
Just a little bit of, like-- is it, like, Brian or something?
只是一点点……是，Brian之类的吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Brian, I should say, is the straight-A student whose parents pressure him to get good grades, played by Anthony Michael Hall.
我应该说，Brian是那个父母迫使他拿到好成绩的全优生，由Anthony Michael Hall饰演。
You kind of feel like Brian?
你有点觉得像Brian？
I do, kind of.
我有点觉得。
He's really sweet, isn't he?
他真的很甜，不是吗？
I know, but you kind of, like, sometimes pressure me in school. [LAUGHS NERVOUSLY]
我知道，但有时你在学校里确实会给我压力。[紧张地笑]
Wait, you think I pressure you?
等等，你觉得我给你压力了？
No, but barely. Like--
不，但很少。就像……
Wow, really?
哇，真的吗？
No! Not anymore! No! I take that back.
不！再也没有了！不！我收回那句话。
Wait, wait. Wait, no, no, no. No, tell me. Tell me. Oh, hey!
等等，等等。等等，不，不，不。不，告诉我。告诉我。噢，嘿！
[SOBBING]
[抽泣]
Hey! No, it's OK. No, no, no. Sweetie. Hey, it's OK!
嘿！不，没事的。不，不，不。甜心。嘿，没事的！
(CRYING) OK.
（哭泣）好的。
It's OK.
没事的。
OK.
好的。
I'm just-- I'm just surprised.
我只是……我只是很惊讶。
(CRYING) But I told you, barely!
（哭泣）但我跟你说了，很少！
Just barely, like a little bit.
只是很少，有一点点。
Yeah.
是啊。
OK, well, you know what? That's really good for me to know. I had no idea. Like, when did I make you feel like that?
好的，你知道吗？这对我来说真的很好。我完全不知道。比如，我什么时候让你有那种感觉？
When you kept on saying, like, I wish I did better in school.
当你一直说，比如，我希望我在学校表现得更好时。
Oh, because I said that I wish I did better in school? So--
噢，因为我说我希望我在学校表现得更好？所以……
And like, you wanted me to do good.
而且你希望我表现好。
Oh, I'm sorry I made you feel that way.
噢，对不起我让你有那种感觉。
But you don't anymore.
但你现在不这样了。
Do you remember the things she's talking about, of you saying to her, like, oh, I wish that I had done better in school?
你记得她谈论的那件事吗，关于你说，噢，我希望我在学校表现更好？
[SIGHS] I was really surprised. I was not expecting that at all. And the only thing that I can think of, really, is we have this homework battle. And it's incredibly frustrating. And--
[叹气] 我真的很惊讶。我完全没预料到。我唯一能想到的就是我们之间那场作业大战。这简直让人抓狂。而且……
It's frustrating to get her to do the work.
让她做作业真是令人沮丧。
Yeah because it's really easy. I mean and I'm not just saying that as an adult. I mean, it's easy.
是啊，因为这很容易。我是说，我不是仅仅作为成年人这么说。我是说，这很容易。
It's easy work for her.
这对她来说是简单的任务。
It's easy work for her. If she would just sit down, do it, it would take 15 minutes, 20 minutes. But she resents the fact that she has to do it so much, and it became such a battle, that she would sort of lie, sprawled out, kind of barely write-- you couldn't even read her writing.
这对她来说很简单。如果她能坐下来做，只需要15分钟，20分钟。但她非常厌恶不得不去做这件事，这成了一场大战，她会躺在那里，伸展开来，几乎不怎么写字——你甚至读不懂她的字。
And I would just get so frustrated with her, and you know, and I would yell at her and say, you can do better than this. You're smarter than this. You know, all the things that parents say. And I think it must have affected her.
我会对她感到非常沮丧，你知道，我会对她大喊大叫说，你可以做得比这更好。你比这更聪明。你知道，所有父母都会说的话。我觉得这一定影响了她。
And then, she said, well, you don't do it anymore. You know, and the reason why I don't do it anymore is because I don't do her homework with her anymore, because I can't. I find it too frustrating.
然后，她说，嗯，你不再那样了。你知道，我不再那样做的原因是，我不再陪她写作业了，因为我做不到。我觉得太令人沮丧了。
When she said that, I thought, like, oh, is she just being protective of you, you know?
当她说那话时，我心想，噢，她是仅仅在保护你吗？你知道？
I think she was being protective of me, too. I think the thing that I noticed the most was Mathilda kind of wanting to make me feel OK. She really did not want to hurt my feelings or make me upset, and she wants to please me, too. I can hear that when I-- [SIGHS] Yeah.
我觉得她也在保护我。我注意到最多的是Mathilda那种想要让我感觉良好的愿望。她真的不想伤害我的感情或者让我难过，而且她也想讨好我。当我……[叹气] 是的，我能听到那个。
Well, the fact that the next thing that happens-- she instantly goes to, I have better parents than they do.
好吧，接下来发生的事实是——她立刻转向说，我有比他们更好的父母。
I know, like it's scripted. I know.
我知道，就像写好的剧本。我知道。
So is there anything else that you got out of the movie that you--
所以你从电影里还得到了什么……
Um, like, well, I have better parents than them.
嗯，就像，好吧，我有比他们更好的父母。
[LAUGHS] You're just saying that to make me feel better. Come on.
[笑] 你只是为了让我感觉更好才这么说。来吧。
I mean, it was bizarre how she just said the thing that I hoped she would get out of it. She knows. I mean, she can intuit that. She knew that I was hoping for that. Yeah, she was giving me a little present, wrapped in a bow.
我是说，她竟然脱口而出我希望她从中得到的东西，这太奇怪了。她知道。我是说，她能直觉到。她知道我在希望那样。是的，她给了我一份用蝴蝶结包装的小礼物。
But at a moment where it doesn't feel like that at all.
但在那一刻，感觉根本不是那样。
No. No, not at all.
不。不，完全不是。
The whole thing, after wondering a lot about what happened when Mathilda cried and how she handled it, and should she have let Mathilda talk for longer, and should she have asked her more questions or different questions-- you know, you just can never know what things that you say to your kids are going to stay with them, and just little things, said in a passing moment, that are going to bounce around in their heads and lead them to conclusions that you don't intend or expect in any way.
整件事，在想了很久关于Mathilda哭泣时发生了什么、她是怎么处理的、Molly是否应该让Mathilda说久一点、是否应该问她更多或不同的问题——你知道，你永远无法知道你对孩子说的哪些话会留在他们心中，那些在转瞬即逝的时刻里说出的小事，会在他们脑海里跳动，导致他们得出你根本没预料到的结论。
Yeah. I think there's always moments where you perceive things differently. I know it with my own mom and dad. I mean, there are times where I'll tell a story that I've heard a million times over the years, you know, and my mom will just completely switch it up, or she'll see it completely differently.
是啊。我觉得总有那么一些时刻，你对事情的感知不同。我对我自己的妈妈和爸爸也是这样。我是说，有的时候我会讲一个我多年来听过几百万遍的故事，你知道，我妈妈会完全改写它，或者她会看到完全不同的东西。
Like some story from your childhood, like you're telling this story about something they did or--
比如你童年的某个故事，就像你正在讲述某件他们做过的事或者……
Yeah.
是啊。
And they're just like, no, no, no.
然后他们只是说，不，不，不。
Well, yeah. I mean, there's one. You know, I come from a family where my sister was sort of designated as the great beauty in the family. And this was just, like, known. My sister--
好吧，是啊。我是说，有一个。你知道，我来自一个家庭，我的姐姐被视为家庭里的绝世美女。这简直是……公认的。我的姐姐……
I was the talented one, my brother was the smart one, and my sister was the beautiful one. And I remember actually asking my mom at-- I must have been around Mathilda's age-- if she thought that I was pretty. And she said, you're cute. And--
我是有才华的那个，我哥哥是聪明的那个，我姐姐是漂亮的那个。我记得我确实问过我妈妈——那时候我大概和Mathilda年纪差不多大——她是否觉得我漂亮。她说，你很可爱。而且……
Ooh.
噢。
Yeah, and that is really not what you want to hear when you're-- (LAUGHING) 10 years-- I mean, now, it's OK. I would be OK with cute. But when you're 10, it was just devastating.
是啊，当你10岁的时候，那真不是你想听到的。（笑）我是说，现在，没关系。我会接受“可爱”。但当你10岁的时候，那简直是毁灭性的。
And-- and she completely denies that now. And I mean, something that would have such an impact on me-- I mean, I just-- I wasn't making it up. It really affected me.
而且……她现在完全否认这一点。我是说，这种对我产生那么大影响的事情——我……我并不是编造的。它真的影响了我。
And she just says it didn't happen.
她只是说那没发生。
She says, oh, I always knew that you were beautiful. You know, ask your father.
她说，噢，我一直都知道你很漂亮。你知道，去问你父亲。
And obviously, like, if she had any idea how it would bounce around in your head, she would have never said it, too. She didn't think like, oh, that's going to stick.
显然，如果她知道这会在你脑子里怎么跳动，她也绝不会那样说。她没想过，噢，那会让人耿耿于怀。
(LAUGHING) No, no. I don't think that she did.
[笑] 不，不。我不觉得她有那种想法。
I have a friend. Her mom would tell her and her sister, no, you girls are average.
我有位朋友。她妈妈总是对她和她妹妹说，不，你们女孩很普通。
Oh!
噢！
No, no, like, you guys are-- you girls are average. You know, like, you're smart, but you're average smart. And I was like, wow, you were not raised by Jews, man. [LAUGHTER]
不，不，就像，你们女孩很普通。你知道，就像，你们很聪明，但你们的聪明很普通。我心想，哇，你没在犹太人家里长大，哥们。[笑声]
That is not the message you get. I mean, in my experience, there's a lot of, you're so special. You're the most special. You're so special. You know, like, the boys and the girls. You know, like, she's the most talented--
那不是你得到的讯息。我是说，在我的经验里，有很多“你是如此特别”。“你是最特别的”。“你是如此特别”。你知道，就像，男孩和女孩。你知道，就像，她是最有才华的……
Well, I was always told that I was special. I mean, there was no question that I was special and that I was destined for greatness.
嗯，我总是被告知我很特别。我是说，我毫无疑问很特别，而且命中注定会成就伟大。
As a little kid?
小时候？
As a little kid.
小时候。
Wow.
哇。
From the time that I was really little. I mean, to the point where-- [CHUCKLES] this is kind of heavy, but I'll tell you anyway. My first brother died. He was the first, and I was the last, so we never met. But my mom was understandably just devastated by this and was sort of suicidal for a while. I mean, didn't actually try anything, but she was considering, and then was-- [LAUGHS] this makes her sound so hippy dippy, and she's not at all.
从我还是很小的时候起。我是说，到那种程度——[轻笑] 这有点沉重，但我还是告诉你吧。我的第一个哥哥去世了。他是第一个，我是最后一个，所以我们从没见过面。但我妈妈显然为此心碎，有一段时间甚至有点自杀倾向。我是说，没真的尝试什么，但她在考虑，然后……[笑] 这让她听起来很嬉皮，但她一点也不。
But she believes that she conversed with a spirit. And what they said, basically-- and this is a story that I've heard since I was very small-- that she was here for another reason, for someone else. And as soon as I was born, she knew that it was me.
但她相信她和灵魂对话过。他们说的话，基本上——这是我从小听到的故事——她来这里是为了另一个原因，为了另一个人。我一出生，她就知道是我。
That's a lot to put on you.
那对你来说压力太大了。
Yeah. It's heavy. (LAUGHING) It's really--
是啊。这很沉重。（笑）这真的很……
She told you that when you were a little girl, that she was put on this Earth because of you?
她告诉你那话时你还是个小女孩，说她来到地球是因为你？
She believed that that was why-- yeah, I mean, because she knew that there was some reason why she was supposed to stick around and--
她相信那确实是原因——是啊，我是说，因为她知道她命中注定要留下来的某个原因，为了……
And stay alive. And it was to have this little girl, who was you, who was such a special gift to the world.
为了活下去。而那是为了拥有这个小女孩，也就是你，你是给世界的一份特别礼物。
Yeah.
是啊。
So how strange that you would end up famous by the age of 15 or something.
所以你竟然在15岁左右就出名了，这太奇怪了。
Well, I kind of had to. I mean, I kept my mom alive.
嗯，我不得不出名。我是说，我让我妈活了下来。
And so then, when you actually did become a movie star as a teenager, did she take that as proof? Like, oh, see, that was all true?
所以当你十几岁时真的成了电影明星，她把它当作证明吗？比如，噢，你看，那全是真的？
Yeah.
是啊。
And did you, at the time? Like, did the whole story fit together for you, too?
而当时你呢？就像，整个故事对你来说也契合了吗？
Yeah. I had to succeed. I had to be great.
是啊。我必须成功。我必须成就伟大。
What a lot of pressure on you.
你压力太大了。
I know. And then, what do I do? I turn around, and I pressure my daughter, because I think she's so great. I know.
我知道。然后呢，我做了什么？我转过头来，给我女儿施压，因为我觉得她太棒了。我知道。
Yeah.
是啊。
Ira J. Glass with Molly Ringwald. She's still acting and translating, and she's working on a new book about her Paris years. And Mathilda-- she's in college now and just finished filming her first movie.
Ira J. Glass与Molly Ringwald。她依然在演戏和翻译，正在写一本关于她巴黎岁月的书。而Mathilda——她现在在读大学，刚拍完她的第一部电影。
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Ira Glass. Our senior producer for this show was Julie Snyder.
我们节目今天由Jonathan Menjivar制作，Alex Blumberg、Ben Calhoun、Sean Cole、Stephanie Foo、Chana Joffe-Walt、Sarah Koenig、Brian Reed、Robyn Semien、Alissa Shipp和Ira Glass协助。我们节目的高级制作人是Julie Snyder。
Production help from Simon Adler and Lilly Sullivan, additional production help on today's rerun from James Bennett II, Michael Comite Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream over 800 of our episodes for absolutely free.
Simon Adler和Lilly Sullivan提供了制作帮助，James Bennett II、Michael Comite、Katherine Rae Mondo、Stowe Nelson和Matt Tierney在今天重播节目中提供了额外制作帮助。我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过800期的节目。
Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Torey Malatia, and to our boss, Mr. Ira Glass. While he was hosting the show recently, he spent a little time moonlighting as a realtor. He's really got to work on his pitch.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的创始人Torey Malatia，以及我们的老板Ira Glass先生。当他最近主持节目时，他花了一些时间兼职做房地产经纪人。他真的得好好练练他的推销话术。
Look at that really [BLEEP] small house over there.
看看那边那个真的[消音]小的房子。
I'm Nancy Updike. Ira Glass will be back with more stories of This American Life.
我是Nancy Updike。Ira Glass将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回归。